عكاز الاقتصاد السوداني هوت فالاخير كان
متكئا على حافه الانهيار حتى قبل بدء صراع
الجنرلين لا يؤذراع الاقتصاديه تمثل بخروج
مطار الخرطوم عن الخدمه اولا ما افقد
خزينه الدوله اكثر من خمسين في المئه من
صادرات البلاد اي صادرات الذهب المقدره
بملياري دولار توقف عمل المطار عطل خمسه
في المئه من اجمالي الصادرات والواردات
فيما طالت معدلات التضخم عتبه الستين في
المئه ارقام وصفها مراقبون بغير الدقيقه
مضيفين ان التضخم فوق ذلك بكثيره نسبه
مماثله قدرت عند قياس معدل الفقر والذي
يتجاوز 60 في المئه فاكثر من اربعين في
المئه من السودانيين قابيعون في خانه
البطاله اما سعر صرف العمله فتدهور بشكل
كبير خلال الفتره الانتقاليه وايام الصراع
الاولى مسجلا انخفاضا قياسيا امام الدولار
ليصل الى 600 جنيه حاليا هذه الارقام قد
تصبح خجوله اذا ما اتسعت رقعه الصراع
الجغرافيه الضيقه والمنحصره بالخرطوم
حاليا ففي حين توقف مطار الخرطوم الا ان
الموانئ لا تزال تعمل سته عشره ولايه
سودانيه لم تتاثر بالنزاع حتى اللحظه
بينها الولايات الشرقيه مثل القضارف وكسلا
وبورتسودان وولايه نهر النيل وهي تؤمن
الطرق من موقع الموانئ الى العاصمه
لكن في حال تمددت رقعه الحرب سيتاثر
الاحتياطي المحلي الاجمالي وسيتفاقم
التضخم وتنهار قيمه العمله اكثر واكثر
فخمسه وثمانون في المئه من حجم الصادرات
والواردات الكليه البالغه 15 مليار دولار
سنويا تتم عبر الموانئ البحريه في
بورتسودان والبحر الاحمر فيما العشره في
المئه المتبقيه تشق طريقها الى الجاره
المصريه عبر مينا اي ارجين وشكات
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات